so let's talk about the unit of
measurement called the gram
and the gram is a unit of measurement
for measuring mass
now what is mass
well you might have seen in everyday
language someone might look at a feather
let me see if i can draw
a good feather so a feather like this
and say hey this is not very massive
this is not
massive and notice you have that word
mass in there and then they might point
to some big
boulder
some big heavy
boulder let me draw a big heavy boulder
and say this is massive
this is
massive
and so just with those examples you
might get an intuition for what mass is
it's how much it's how much stuff there
is and it's related to weight and i said
related to weight not the same thing as
weight because later on when you take
physics you will learn that mass and
weight are related but they're not
exactly the same thing
now if you're on a given planet and the
same distance from the center of that
planet roughly speaking mass and weight
will be strongly related to each other
something with more mass is going to
have more weight two things with the
same mass once again if i'm on the same
planet at the same distance from the
center of the planet they're going to
have the same weight so you'll often
hear people say
how many grams does that thing weigh
they really should be saying how many
grams does that thing mass but it's okay
because as long as we're staying on
earth roughly you know at sea level plus
or minus a little bit or even if we're a
little bit further away from sea level
mass and weight it's it's not crazy to
hold them a little bit interchangeable
and one way to to gauge something's mass
is to hold it and if you can and say
okay how much does this weigh because
the more something weighs the more its
mass is going to be the more its mass is
going the more something's mass is going
to be the more it's going to weigh once
again assuming we're on the planet
etcetera etcetera when you take physics
class you'll learn that they are
different concepts that are closely
related to each other
so that's what a gram is now another
thing that you will see in the context
of mass and measuring mass is the
kilogram
kilo
kilogram and all the kilogram is
all the kilogram is and you're going to
see the prefix kilo over and over again
or kilo or kilo over and over again in
your
in your i guess your education careers
especially when you're thinking about
units but kilo is just a prefix for a
thousand so that literally means one
thousand grams
so instead of saying
two thousand grams i could say two
kilograms so with that out of the way
let's see if we can get a sense for
what one gram or different numbers of
grams of masses are and what different
numbers what might have a mass of one
kilogram or 10 kilograms or 100
kilograms
and that's exactly why
i got all of these pictures prepared
so if you want to get a sense of
something that has a mass
of one
one gram think of a paper clip and i
have this little squiggly thing here
because that right there that means
roughly every paperclip isn't going to
be exactly one gram it might be one and
a half grams they might be small
paperclips that are half a gram but it
gives you the sense of what would have a
mass of one gram and if you want to know
how much something with a mass of one
gram weighs on the surface of the earth
well you can just hold that paper clip
and kind of judge on
feel how much it's pulling down on on
your hand
now or how much the the weight of it is
pushing down on your hand i guess i
could say now if you want to get a sense
of things that are a little bit more
massive a pencil is five times as
massive as a paper clip and hopefully
you'll see that if you hold five paper
clips in one side and a pencil on the
other side you'll see that they roughly
have the same mass and they'll be the
their weight will be roughly the same
now a little bit more massive you could
think of a field mouse a field mouse is
equivalent to the mass of roughly four
pencils or 20 paper clips you want to
get even more massive you can think of a
kitten
so a kitten after a couple of weeks it's
still a kitten now it's still not a
fully grown cat it'll have a mass of
about 200 to 300 grams and this makes
this makes rough rough amount of sense
you can imagine this thing having the
same mass as maybe 10 or 15 of these
little field mice you can imagine the
mouse the mouse is is about
it's about that size right over there so
that let me see if i can draw this and
knows i could do a better job drawing
the mouse but that makes that makes some
sense
so what if we get even larger what if we
get into the ranges of say a thousand
grams well now we can start talking
about kilograms and just as just to be
clear when i put a g here that's just an
abbreviation for gram so this is one
gram
five grams 20 grams
and now if you want to go to a thousand
grams you could think of something like
a
a hard cover a hard cover textbook like
this one and they're you know obviously
some textbooks are huge but the one that
i'm showing here i didn't weigh or
figure out the mass of this exact one
but it would have a mass of roughly one
kilogram or one thousand grams so that's
a kilogram right over there a thousand
grams a fully grown cat that's about
three to five kilograms depending on how
fully grown it is or i guess just how
big of a cat it is so that's pretty
interesting a fully grown cat is more
than 10 times the mass
more than 10 times the mass
of a kitten actually that makes sense
most fully grown humans are more than 10
times their mass when they were when
they were very very young or actually
roughly 10 times the mass of when they
were very young so it actually makes it
actually makes it actually makes sense
now if you want to get even larger you
can go to a large ape like a human being
in particular this one right over here
70 kilograms and this is actually pretty
close to my actual mass 70 kilograms and
just to get a sense of what that would
mean if you're used to dealing with
pounds i weigh about 100 and a little
over 160 pounds so that's about 70
kilograms or one kilogram is roughly 2.2
pounds if you are used to thinking in
terms of pounds but once again pounds
are a unit of weight while kilograms are
a unit of mass and then if you want to
get even heavier you want to get 10
times or i could say 10 times more
massive than a human being than a normal
size human being you might get to
something like this cow and this cow
would have a mass of 750 kilograms so
how many paper clips would you need to
have the same mass as this cow
well you might be tempted to say 750 but
remember this is one gram this is
750 kilograms so the mass of this cow is
actually 750
grams so you would need about 750 000 of
these paper clips to have the same mass
as this cow